the two blue lines in this figure appear
to be curved
when i remove the diagonal lines inside
it's obvious to see they're parallel
once the lines are drawn back in
they appear to be curved once again
the red lines appear to be curved and
wavy
but removing alternate sets of
rectangles
the lines are all parallel and straight
the diagonal lines appear to be slanted
with some parts of them appearing closer
to the others
but removing the smaller lines
the diagonal lines are all straight and
parallel to each other
the rectangles at the top
appear to be
rising towards the center and the
rectangles at the bottom seem to be
falling towards the center
the effect even remains after drawing
horizontal lines
but the rectangles on each of the lines
are all horizontally aligned
as you can see when i remove the
rectangles
this shape appears to be a spiral going
towards the center
but it's actually made up of concentric
circles where each circle has small
rectangles
the shape starts with one big circle
made out of rectangles
we make a copy of that inside
and we copy the figure again
and very quickly it appears to be a
spiral
all of these figures appear to be
trapezoids
and the two figures at the bottom appear
to be slanted so it's falling towards
the right
when i remove the lines inside
it reveals that these are all rectangles
and all the line edges of the figures
are straight
the figure inside the circles appears to
be a star-shaped
diamond
but removing the circles
it's easy to see this is
a square diamond and all of its edges
are straight
the line behind the cylinder appears to
jump
but removing the cylinder
we see that the line was actually
connected the whole time
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory
you can catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions or on twitter at
preshtalwalker